it's time for ETS social study your  quick look at what the Stars are posting  online  demi lovato rocked out to her ex Joe  Jonas band dnce on Wednesday night with  her new boyfriend MMA fighter Guilherme  vasconcelos while the weekend cozied up  to Naomi Campbell now the two aren't a  couple the singer captioned to the pic  big sis I always wanted you know a house  full of life and laughter Heidi Klum is  one a proud mama  check out this super sweet shot she  shared with all her kiddos snuggled  together in bed Dwayne the rock Johnson  also showed off his daughter  fifteen-year-old Simone she was his  People's Choice Awards date the star  celebrated his big win at the show with  a drink captured in this celebratory  snap oh yes I'm 100% of Twitter and  Instagram addict and we know Chrissy  Teigen isn't shy about what she posts  online so here's her latest selfie her  stretch marks the model captioned the  pic whatevs  [Music]  you